what else you got nick we got nick
in wisconsin i'm sure you've had some
dudes roll up on you with some cheese a
nice cut
sharp chicken yeah i've only met nice
older men
i don't know i was an altar boy for uh
from kindergarten sixth grade but i
think they
thought i would tell on them that
must've got one that must have gotten
weird
no they're really nice guys somebody
looked up to him yeah there you go
yeah i even janitor at the rectory on
weekends on occasion
the craziest part of that chat chat is
with
the old guy comes down the middle of the
aisle and just sprinkles everybody
yeah that's the part where it's like
whoa
they were all really good people man
just nothing that's christ bro
yeah um that's how it should work and
you were on the church cheerleading team
give me a g
give me an l give me an a give me a him
give me a
that's the lamb baby no i was not on the
church cheerleading team there we go
is there a church cheerleading team
there probably is yeah like
aggressive p.e aggressive yeah probably
like some little christian youth group
they probably haven't like
bet they suck if you became the church
cheerleader dog dolla dolla bills don't
have to pay taxes
around the country doing backflips for
the lord another brilliant business idea
i don't know how many of those backflips
i got left tighten up dude you got to do
the lord's help you could do a ton of
them
he's got a point yeah dude you start
doing
christian back flips you're slinging
barbecue yeah then hosting games
the christ is right the christ is right
come on down
wins i flip come on up come on come on
up
come on up because that's what lord i
lift your name on high yeah
the mountain climber goes to uh heaven
instead yeah oh
yeah you fall off go to hell yeah here
you go man
jesus christ how many ideas
we got a lot of beautiful ideas for me i
think how many ideas you've done with
one you know
yeah i am and when you run with the lord
you can never lose
yep you can't lose man so who else got
melissa chen
you're a big korean kid in texas i'm
sure
i didn't get molested but there was a
there was a strange
guy that was supposedly like a nice
person he worked at the church
so me and my friends this was when i was
what keep going
yeah keep going we're just listening to
you so he lived in the neighborhood
yep and then he would ask us to hang out
and then
he would talk about god you know how
great god is and we would ask him like
questions like
oh if you go to heaven can you
skateboard all day because we're you
know in the skateboarding so he's like
yeah i could do everything
praise god stupid question the people
the parents didn't like him
but we thought he was the nicest nicest
guy because he's worked at the church
and everything sure
he smoked cigarettes okay he had long
hair okay
and then once one day he was talking
about how baptizing is awesome and great
yeah so he baptized us in his backyard
with his pants off no with the water
water hose with a water hose yeah he
goes it doesn't matter where the water
comes from it just has to be blessed
dude just want to see some boys wet so
i'm looking back i think maybe
you know maybe something could have
happened if we didn't like yeah
he sure was a water hose dude yeah he
could have us in his
dick he could have painted his wiener
green and put a little metal on the end
of it yeah yeah
somebody it's a hot day it's worth it
just popped up right now i kind of just
i'm glad you got it out though thanks
dude everybody got a little bit molested
and i know that um
they had a man us that was a religious
type of man you know
and he uh he used to get us high
then he would get us weed you know and
at the time we thought he was cool guy
that's how he goes looking back he was
70 year old man
hanging out buying weed for 15 year olds
and why is he doing it so it's a little
dicey
high enough you think his dick is a
playground i mean it's cool yeah but
it's a little dicey you know
hell yeah it's dicey like hey you want
to slide down this short slide
whoa you wanna jump on these monkey bars
but he would get us high and then he
bought us some baked potatoes one time
this dude richard bangenstein was his
last name
definitely dead alarming name he is dead
hot potatoes he got us some steaks and
potatoes and we've never had steaks and
potatoes
it sounds like a nice guy to be honest
that's where we were at this point
brendan
and then what happened was everybody got
high
and was eating their meal and i was in
the
kitchen and i said hey does anybody want
some
uh sour cream i yelled that yeah
and my buddy scott goes uh you can have
some of this sweet oh my buddy scott
goes hey will you give me some sour
cream
and i said no but i'll get you some of
this sweet cream you know
i was talking about semen making jokes
[Laughter]
and then he goes can i have some oh
and then were you like check please
it was like i think we're good on that
guy all the breaks in my head just
slammed on
and i was like damn this dude's gonna
molest somebody and i didn't even tell
my friends
i was just like i gotta get out of here
and then his friends keep going back
eating potatoes and sweet cream that's
their life bro
you know they'll have to share their
story when they're ready yeah we have
them on next week
yeah what happened next week
theo had a lot of stuff happening we had
a basketball coach pam to look at his
butthole from 20 feet away
he had another older man make him lick
cinnamon out of his hand
wait what hold on
you want to have a seat
[Laughter]
whoa what's up with the cinnamon liquid
my dad's friend man
so what so he was like hey you like
churros you're like yeah he's like all
right
go ahead and try this [ __ ] finger
no man he had a little bit of cinnamon
this one not everybody had cinnamon man
not everybody had it you know
if you liked it it wasn't a bunch of his
hair like a bird
so someone so if someone had it it was
like damn you got cynical he would sneak
you a little behind his back you know
was it the powder or the stick it was a
powder okay cause i should chew on the
sticks
so what happened and that's not moleski
at all
you dude if you look you know who choose
on the sticks chew on the sticks
and suck on the beans you know you
chewed on the sticks somebody that
started on the powder that's for sure
so and then what happened to the
basketball coach you looked at your
butthole yeah no this guy used to pay us
give us a little bit of money and he
would show his
behold about 40 feet off well this is
you know
polite i guess i mean this is a
different time man everything wasn't a
crime back then and we thought he was
crazy
no matter what year you're in you know
when you call the police you're like hey
some guy's showing me his pedal from 40
feet away
to kids they're going to rest that dude
yeah brother you see you see they're not
see but you're you're a victim
you're a victim and you think it's all
good you know justifying it oh come on
gary was cool
man well what happened was let's eat
cinnamon
the cops knew us and they knew our
neighbor this lady miss cheryl had a car
that had uh alarm on it
it was like the first car alarm in our
in our area and so
he's like go out there and push cheryl's
car and that'll scare him off that's
what that's what the cop said
so he got there and shake her car and
then the alarm would go off and then
anything that was going on that
shouldn't have been people would tighten
up that makes sense
[Music]
is